herzlich kommt sollen die leute ich habe
es heute wieder ein krasses video
rausgesucht und zwar sehen wir heute ein
video über eine frau die über sich
selbst sagt dass ihr beruf es ist frau
von einem millionär zu sein das ist
natürlich eine aussage bei der ich mir
gut vorstellen können dass in
deutschland bei einem
durchschnittsgehalt von ich weiß es
nicht 45.000 euro oder so einige
menschen sich denken bruder der titel
allein gibt es schon hinweis darauf dass
hier einiges an sprengstoff drin sein
könnte wir schauen rein und legen jetzt
wo sie lebt in einer villa in
deutschland und in einer villa auf
mallorca häuser sind groß die klunker
auch das ist zwar ok also ja hier haben
sie es wird land das ist die dame um die
es geht
was uns auf jeden fall ins auge springt
als allererstes wenn wir dieses jahr ist
schon wie dieser dieser beitrag gemacht
ist leute was war ihre erste reaktion
also in diesen beitrag gesehen habt ihr
hatte ich gerade denke ich habe jetzt
schon so einen hals wenn ich diesen
titel leser jetzt will ich die zeit mir
irgendwas in dem video worüber ich mich
was machen kannst
das ist zwar nah und damit eher
millionen ihres mannes lebt sie in saus
und braus
ok also gut damals auch schon geklärt
ihr beruf ist schon mal tatsächlich
millionärsgattin oder millionärs frau
dank der millionen ihres mannes lebt sie
in saus und braus eine sache durch dazu
vorne weg sein bevor ihr jetzt alle auf
die barrikaden springt jetzt kurz okay
es kann auch in einer ehe ein sehr
fairer die sein dass eine partei sagte
ich gearbeitet und die andere sagt ich
habe mich um die kinder und den haushalt
wenn die wirklich dann ihr versprechen
auch halten dass ich dann irgendwann
sagen tut mir jetzt also die schreiben
dann gibt s drum aber an sich kann das
auch eine lösung sein
es liegt also da haben sie es wirklich
einige mühe geben müssen wir sagen bei
der kamera krieges gefehlt hat jeder
richtig schöne stadt aufzusetzen damit
auch jeder sofort weiß diese frau ist
reich ok auf gar keinen fall hätte man
so was wie zu drehen können wo man eher
wie ein park geht oder so oder irgendwie
schöne landschaft oder nein es muss
geflext werden champagner kühler ist da
obstteller ist da sofa ist da das
aussieht als hätte ein französischer
könig zu
drauf ein kind zeugt ja kann man glaube
ich sagen also sie fährt einen porsche
cayenne ist jetzt stand heute würde man
sagen altes modell ich geh mit sehr
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit davon aus dass
als dieses video gedreht wurde das denn
nagelneu war und wie gesagt ich habe es
eben schon gesagt heute die couch auf
der ein französischer könig seinen thron
nachfolger gezeugt haben könnte ist also
ich meine es gibt ja auch die seinen
kunden wie auch krass sind so couch ein
design coaches die auch krass sind die
auch teuer sind wenn es teuer sein muss
die arbeit die sei mäßig modern schlicht
aussehen das ist wiederum die andere
seite hier dass sie wirklich so aus wie
eine karte die man sich in sein schloss
stellen würde
zwei kleine hatten ähnlich sein personal
aber oft es die einfach nur in der
mutter am rande des nervenzusammenbruchs
ist ja wirklich wild alter bruder ist
ein schmetterlinge dass es das ist ein
ganz wilder druck auf jeden fall kann
ich ja letzte so zertifizieren es gibt
euch einen in den vereinigten staaten
von amerika gibt so in der in den
ghettos und so und in der rap kultur
gibt es irgend so ein ding das man sich
so ein vorfall ring road leute so bringt
der überall die finger geht man alle
vier finger rein steckt und dann steht
dann irgendwas drauf teletubbies hat
einfach keine ahnung dass ihr geht schon
krass in diese richtung alter das schon
es ist ein klunker exklusiv gewährt sie
uns einen einblick in den stressigen
alltag einer millionärsgattin
er läutete bei dabei kannte ja der
stelle mal kurz irritiert ich sagen
selbstverständlich gehen auch die
eigenen probleme nicht ganz weg nur weil
man millionärin ist oder ein millionärs
garten hat man zusammen in der er
millionen hat die sache ist nur das geld
einmal stress nehmen kann
das ist definitiv so aber ich bin nach
wie vor der meinung dass geld an sich
nicht glück bringen kann geld kann
glücklicher machen sehr wohl also wenn
man weniger stress hat weniger probleme
hat klar macht dass glücklicher es kann
kurzfristig freude machen wenn man sich
ein petn jets gezielt oder geil das
motorrad oder so aber eben nicht
dauerhaft wir treffen svetlana also das
sage ich damit ihr nicht denkt dass dies
hilft leider sei es jetzt in alien ist
oder so und auf dem anderen planeten
lebt also am ende gehört das ist das ist
natürlich ganz wichtig leute das ist
natürlich ganz wichtig einerseits muss
man auch sagen ich kann verstehen wenn
ein geld wirklich egal ist sagen wir man
fühlt sich 50 millionen euro auf dem
konto hat und seid ihr ja was jucken
nicht 300 euro oder 5 euro für baby g t
shirt dann mache ich es einfach so dann
kann ich es verstehen so ok für die
allermeisten von uns ist es glaube ich
keine kluge idee unser baby in gut zu
kleiden oder louis vitton oder hermès
auch wenn ms noch deutlich schöner ist
was ich damit sagen möchte ist sollte
dass kinder die in gucci gekleidet sind
definitiv zu besseren menschen werden
und auch die bessere kindheit haben
falls ihr manchmal durchs leben geht und
ich fragte warum nimmt das leben nicht
einfach so hopps es liegt daran dass sie
als kinder nicht in gucci gekleidet war
[Musik]
also das war jetzt nicht so geil digger
über satte kennst du kennst du du
mittelschichtler das war wirklich also
deine arme und katzen ja sowas von an
muss sich jetzt erklären was falsch ist
ja die ist ja wirklich komplett in
feschen alter also gut ich muss dazu
sagen philipp lahm
dieser betrag ist ein bisschen älter
philipp lahm ist heute wirklich muss ich
sagen ein absolutes no go was luxus
markt angeht neben einigen anderen
natürlich möglicherweise war das damals
anders leute aber wir sehen auf jeden
fall ihr das wittlager ihre kinder auf
den richtigen weg begibt leute diese
kinder werden eines tages glücklich sein
und das liegt an der burberry leggings
die mädchen werden täglich von
wechselnden nannys betreut
ohne hilfe wäre es wird lange einfach zu
stressig aber einer fehlt wo ist das
oberhaupt der beitrag ist auch schon so
der beitrag ist schon im existiert ein
bisschen der ist schon so darauf
ausgelegt dass und sie haben sie
manchmal mit sicherheit im plan
geschrieben wie der beitrag am ende sein
soll dass der zuschauer sich denkt der
ja also diese svetlana die geben mir
richtig auf sagt man muss wissen was man
will
man kann aber auf jeden fall also was
man generell nicht machen kann glaube
ich da ist zu sagen das ist komplett
falsch was die gerade machen also
allgemein gilt in deutschland ja schon
aus dem leistungsprinzip checken was ich
meine leute und wenn leute sachen
bekommen ohne dafür die arbeit gemacht
zu haben dann träger dass leute immer
das tool jetzt soll das
gerechtigkeitsempfinden von leuten kann
man auch voll verstehen heißt im
umkehrschluss aber nicht das beispiel
jetzt kann wenn ich jetzt millionär wäre
hätte 20 30 40 millionen und ich treffe
halt ne frau und denke mir gehabt diese
frau will ich dass ich meine kinder
großzieht und ich will die komplett
verwöhnen mit allem luxus denn es gibt
ja kein gesetz was mir das verbietet so
also steckt ihr fast lama selbst in
ihrer kindheit nicht hatte bietet sie
nun im
überfluss ihren beiden töchtern gehören
luxuslimousine ist selbstverständlich
mit monitoren ausgestattet die
luxuslimousine aja der porsche cayenne
ist also eine limousine
ja man kennt ihn manchmal werden
geländewagen in fernsehbeiträgen einfach
mal zur limousine classic hat sie denkt
sich so decker hat der guard limousine
gesagt hat die off-stimme wirklichkeit
dem musiker zu unseren karrieren gesagt
krieg hier gleich ein anfall
ich schmeiße gleich mein louis
polynesien zunächst für zwei planer zu
einem juwelier sie suchte ein
schmuckstück mit diamanten als geschenk
für ihre tochter letizia
die kleine wird in den kommenden tagen
zwei jahre alt für portugal wird aber
dass er finde ich hab schon fast
fahrlässig zwei jahre alt und hat noch
kein schmuckstück mit diamanten der
garten
also ich hab gerade eben habe ich gesagt
okay ich finde es gut wenn man seine
kinder komplett in nur noch gut ski von
oben bis unten anzieht dass es gut für
den entwicklung aber wenn ihr mit zwei
dann noch keinen diamantring haben da
frage ich ganz ehrlich ist da alles
richtig gelaufen helfen das geht
überhaupt nicht im märz leute in meiner
meinung dazu ist ich kann verstehen dass
wenn sie diese kindheit nicht hat die
gemeinde das hat sich eben gesagt dass
sie aus einem kommunistischen land kam
dass es da eben so etwas wie so krasse
luxus bestand nicht gab das ist deswegen
vielleicht auch so anzieht dass sich das
nicht an den kindern ermöglichen möchte
kann man irgendwo verstehen aber ich
halte es nicht für eine gute idee kinder
zu überschütten mit allen möglichen
materiellen sachen weil das führt dazu
dass die kinder einfach dann schon satt
fürs leben sind so was würden sie dann
machen wenn ich schon alles haben
entscheiden sich nicht dafür zu
interessieren und dass hier kein teil
unter 5000 euro kostet das ist mit
leider interessiert sollte eine
koalabären branche also leute ganz im
ernst jetzt mal ganz im ernst ich muss
ehrlich sagen dieser lebensentwurf wir
hier vorgelebt wird hier gezeigt wird
ist nicht mein idealer wenn ich richtig
viel geld hätte würde ich trotzdem
zumindest versuchen das bisschen loki zu
halten ich persönlich finde jemanden
zuerst vergleich mahlzeit person fiktive
person personal hat fünf millionen lebt
den krassesten luxus lifestyle yachten
porsche whatever alles person b hat auch
fünf millionen aber lebt halt undercover
so muss nicht die krassesten und muss
jemand neues auto kaufen kaufen autos
gebraucht ist immer noch vernünftig
damit dann finde ich personen b
sympathischer
muss ich aber sagen also ja leute kann
man mit viel geld besser leben als mit
wenig geld auf jeden fall kann man sich
mehr leisten auf jeden fall kann einem
das gewisse stressfaktoren im leben
nehmen und mehr freiheiten geben
auf jeden fall muss man deswegen sein
kind von kopf bis fuß in gucci kleinen
jeden tag auf jeden fall also sollte
spart oder geld investierte geld geht
nicht alles für konsum aus und bleibt
stabil hier gibt's einfach ich
vorgeschlagen könnte meint gabriel ich
bin raus